paul nyak says he hasn't seen floods
this bad since the 1960s when he was a
boy flood waters have destroyed crops
blocked access to fields and reduced
grazing land the 56 year old says at
least there is an upside to the
devastation
more water than usual means plenty more
fish is available
it's good for us sometimes united
nations takes long to bring us food this
way we can survive until they can reach
families cut off by the water
much of this agricultural land is now
underwater for the third consecutive
year flood waters have risen as excess
water flows down the nile from
neighboring countries
but families can't survive on just fish
malnutrition rates are increasing as
flooding affects food supplies all
animals that we depend on they are dying
because of the flood all our
houses they are under the water in the
town and this is very difficult
also we get the disease through
the flood
communities used to grow sorghum a
cereal that is easy to cultivate but
there has been no farming here for more
than two years humanitarian aid has also
been affected this used to be our food
distribution point
where we were distributing food to
over
27 000 people here in old fangar with
the support from the world food program
but now because of the flooding we are
now unable to utilize this location
some desperate families collect water
lilies to supplement their diet the
dried flowers from the lilies are ground
into small amounts of cereal it's not
nutritious but there aren't many options
out here
fish is an essential source of protein
when there isn't much else available
south sudan is no stranger to floods but
they're now becoming more frequent too
much water covered 19 poverty and
conflict make the situation here dire
people say they'll have to find ways to
adapt
preserving their catch is one way to
keep food longer in fact small scale
industries of sun drying the fish have
boomed because of the floods but
everywhere they look people are reminded
the situation here could get worse water
levels are not receding fast enough
barriers can only do so much to keep the
rising water at bay
hare mutasa al jazeera jungle state
south sudan